[Music]
all right thank you
so I have mentioned these things to you
I'm gonna start with a big data system
and then talk about theoretical models
again the goal here is to give a
sampling in both the big data system and
the theoretical model part you will see
that there's a number of very
interesting algorithmic questions it's
not easy to stitch together views of
massive or large-scale mobility so
that's very interesting and building
models of simulators one example would
be can we simulate the highway system
here just as a closed system vehicles
from the Indian ramp and off ramp for
example if someone gives you map data or
they give you a large fleet like from
one of the car
you know hailing companies could you
then create a simulator for the highway
system and different traffic and weather
conditions that's not an easy thing to
do and that's very valuable and also and
talk about theoretical models so with
that
so second part is this thing on the
right
big data system I'm not going to talk
about mobile apps but I'll tell you what
the system is in how one can think of it
I also give you an example so think of
it as this was what we did a turbine
engines but it comes from having
commuter data the Washington DC metro
used a system I'm going to show you most
notably
but they're also other we'll just takes
time companies so you can have GPS
records from city buses or packages as
they're moving in trucks or cab type
companies and they all have system of
the type that one wants to see namely
you have to do a lot of this GPS records
are like really noisy GPS itself is
about 1 to 3 meter accurate however the
lore of this is out in the open fields
and stuff but with urban Canyon type
effects there's a lot of multipathing
and you get line-of-sight lost to the
satellite and so you can sometimes be in
streets that are not adjacent streets
not the one you're actually on or you
can be displaced quite a bit from your
actual position in K so you have to do a
lot of what we call data healing this is
just like continuity arguments that if I
see you here and then I lost you and
then you know you must have we know how
to fill it in so that's what this is
saying the gaps can be filled in and
fusion fusion is you are in a bus and
your phone another person's phone is
correlated I know you entered the bus
are you're travelling in the bus because
yours your phone the drivers phone I'm
going together so this is getting other
data different from the one you already
have
I'm then fusing the two to get an
overall picture
with this you can create what we call a
digital replica this is the Singapore
bus system the dots are all buses and
color coding is gray is likely occupied
and yellow and red are heavily occupied
okay yeah when the system was you know
we would you can play this so sort of
play and you would get a digital replica
and you can filter it depending on what
route so if you only want to see the
carded buses and so on you could do that
or if you want to see the buses which
are making money or losing one you can
do a lot okay but you can answer
questions like which deliveries are in
danger of violating deadlines the next
30 minutes okay
of the packages that are in transit
which ones will slip the deadlines a
raisin alert if some packages that this
distribution center is more than 5000
these are sort of things so this could
do but the city bus version but is very
similar for packages and warehouses and
the second thing was not the digital
replica but a database we call it the
movement database movement database the
the indices is like key value pairs and
the keys were typically spatial or
temporal taken from space or time axis
okay so you could draw a circle around
some neighborhood like this and you
could ask for like put this portion of
Manhattan and in that portion of
Manhattan across for speed difference
between this is 5:00 to 7:00 a.m. and
7:00 to 9:00 a.m. so before peak and
during peak for example for trips
emanating in this portion of Manhattan
you could adjust this to whatever you
want it you could pick neighborhoods you
could fuse this with GPS in our sorry
not GPS you could fuse a map with zip
codes so this is just all available okay
you could just say I want these zip
codes or you want these neighborhoods
break it down by neighborhood thinks
this all the the the
world of urban planning and GIS systems
geographic information systems has all
this templates available ok I want the
zip codes of us you'll get this ok so so
it's a very interesting system to try
and build because now you could ask the
zip code based stuff and I'm show you
how we could use this for New York City
Taxi
data analysis analysis of New York City
Taxi later ok so again staying with the
packages this must have been the last
presentation I made to some package
person so this is why it's there how
many fragile I know there was a Stanford
workshop when the Business School on
this how many small fragile packages etc
so what this does is allows you to look
at quarter one versus quarter three I
introduced a bunch of new hybrid
vehicles in my fleet how are they doing
in terms of dollars spent per kilometer
travel or dollars spent per dollar and
things like that ok so that's basically
what you can do and there are several
other things there's there's emulators
and stuff that one can build
emulations of different systems but let
me jump to this thing which is how does
the digital replica don't get created
what's the data and this is sort of what
we use for the Washington DC metro what
I'm going to show you in this this is a
simple map but think of you know a major
oven like bark bar tall so we built this
so you have a tap in this is when a
person who has a smart car for commuting
uses that to enter a train station you
tap into the turnstile which opens and
you enter ok at some point later in time
you will tap out of some other place so
this is your entry and exit point into
the subway system just based on this but
for all the commuters could we figure
out where the trains are okay if we
there are exactly exactly where the
trains are which train this particular
commuter boarded and the reason that's
not obvious is because you have
sometimes enter a train station the
turnstile to walking to the platform and
then Hong Kong for example has the exact
walking times in the off-peak our peak
hour because you have different speeds
you just be squeezed through in the peak
hour and you have to adjust for these
things and then you may not be able to
board the first train that comes because
it's all running full so you queued up
you may miss two or three trains
it's called unable to board that's a
number it's a performance measure okay
this okay so let me show you that system
in the following way start with the raw
data and then
so this is
some of the very early data we had when
we're doing the we got this for the
before launching the instinct project on
the sand commuting so we have this
ticketing data but we didn't know until
a couple of year and a half later that
we could actually use this to recreate
exactly the subway system so this is the
east-west line in Singapore from Joe
Kuhn - Percy Reece in one so Joe Kuhn is
the site is east and this is West
so east to west west to east okay what
is this each vertical line is a station
first station second station third
station they're spaced by the distance
along these two ass line between them
okay so there's six kilometers between
these stations that's what this okay as
an example the y-axis starts or 7:00
a.m. and goes until 9:00 a.m. this is
all the morning peak hour commuter
records each dot is a person tapping
into the station is the arrival time of
passengers at the station okay this
these are all the arrival times happens
these are the tappings in the reverse
direction from here you can't say
anything except that some stages are
more particular popular and others are
less popular you can't see trains
nothing they will queue this okay what
happens if you look at Tapout records or
the expect to see
people are gonna get our in bursts so
David David is sort of drawing a little
bit of Dorothy that dotted line okay so
people have a tendency as soon as the
little subway system first of all they
get out together all the doors swish
open early and they just love to run out
nobody likes the stains I saw with this
lips just okay this like tight back exit
okay so let's see that so as I go to the
exit side you can see these are the
tapout times they already see the trains
it's all visible already okay for
example this is a train dropping people
at different stations and it stopped
here actually so some of them flipped
around and then okay so the
corresponding this is the return there
will be return trip okay so this is like
a flipped around train okay but you get
the idea okay so now imagine how can we
do use this recreate everything okay
this is what we did just just fill in
animation - so the time between trains
is like two three minutes sir just
because I mean yeah of the tap in this
is presumably a function of the
separation between between trains if
you're on a line that ran every 10
minutes presumably people start and
predictable then presumably you were to
get some amount of the bunching on tap
ends that's right so for systems like in
DC in the early morning hours you can
see that because the frequency is a lot
less in the in that hour in DC or even
here for the map but the frequency in
the peak are in Singapore and Hong Kong
it's just much more frequent in fact the
headway constantly keeps getting reduced
because that's the way you can add
capacity and so this is an unusually
long separation between two trains yes
I'm not these are just the tap outs in
the two-hour period this thing will go
from five you know whenever the first
trade is things for four or five in the
morning all the way it's I think it's a
19-hour or some number hours it's going
to be all day I'm only showing it to our
slice okay and so most of these systems
the Train timings are announced as
frequencies how many trains per hour
rather than our time of train
necessarily okay for suburban trains of
the Caltrain type they have scheduled
with with minutes and so on for metro
it's usually how many vehicles per hour
okay so this is an example of tap out
now imagine that you had this record of
tapping tap out for a commuter now what
happens is let's imagine that some guy
captain here at this station they
arrived and tapped in here
okay and then at this station they
tapped out there
okay this so I believe I pointed here
and then I pointed there okay so this
person's history in this single line
case no transfers at the moment I will
tell you are the transfers as soon as I
say that you'll see it you back up this
person boarded the strength therefore
they tapped order these are a bunch of
people so you back up like this this is
when they boarded the Train and this is
when they arrive so they might have
walked to the platform and missed a
couple of trains because they're unable
to board okay I said that's how you do
the single line first you just do all
the single lines then you look at the
guys who transfer that is their origin
and destination stations are not on the
same line okay now there's this puzzle
of where did they transfer because
sometimes you can have somebody
transferring you know in in one place or
another place
and just as like amazing puzzles these
things exist in Singapore Hong Kong just
DC everyone in this place is has I can't
tell which way they went okay and so the
way you can tell the way we could tell
was you look at the exit station so
let's say you went from the you start on
the Green Line and either you have to go
to the blue line and transfer to get
your destination or you're a girl so you
look green followed by blue or your
yellow followed by red these are the
options no I don't know from the
destination Tapout whether you came on
the blue or the red line but then I see
the people who tapped or with you on
what station they boarded and surely
those guys some of them were on the same
line so either they were in the blue or
the right and then I can tell which way
you went okay this it's like I'm doing
it this human animation okay okay so
like you can recurse okay so you can do
this and that's what we did in this
ambiguous cases okay
in other cases pretty obvious there's
only one way you can get there okay and
so you can reconstruct so first you
start the destination back up to the
point of interchange and then see what
trained they could have most likely been
left off at that place and then back it
up okay so the system was built and
validated meaning what does validation
mean here first of all knowledge build
system you say here's how you validate
the system okay
so they you could also you could make a
trip purposefully the David takes this
card he makes a trip he knows exactly
what training to where he transferred
what time he got on the connecting train
and all this stuff and if I can recreate
David's trajectory well then that's good
okay often what happened in these cases
was because David is not idling so he
sort of this busy traveler I was in our
favor you know he wasn't like a guy who
just stopped to the station to the phone
call is the perception of being busy
okay okay
but but you know most urban commuters
are like that no one likes is like you
know so unless they have a phone call or
some other reason they won't step off or
a station okay so what happens is even
if you didn't get you right we've got
you wrong by one train you wanted on
this train where you're in one
laughter okay so it's not easy you can't
be off by ten trick is impossible
because you just have an in-and-out
constraint okay okay this the system is
very interesting because there are lots
of days when it rains and there's when
there are breakdowns and days when the
service level agreements are violated
like these days this is an unusually
large spacing okay
and so it's a system of record and it's
use you know by the transport system
like the public transport system or by
the regulator etc okay but you can do a
lot of things like you know but see how
congestion or how commuting changed over
the last two three years what happened
in this new downtown line got added in
Singapore how did that change commuting
okay they'd have the intended effect
what happens in two new buildings went
up there and Founder new homes came in
these two buildings or etc okay so these
are sort of things that public planning
people like to do and a very interesting
thing I remember because we've done both
the trains and buses a very interesting
question we got was as from the urban
planning people right I'm gonna try
what's this I used to work it over and
is I think he'll remember if I can't
fully remember the question it was
something like this how many people are
changing buses at this station that are
boarding just to begin with that is this
the first starting point versus how many
are transferring some of all the people
boarding this bus number 10 here how
many have transferred from another bus
versus how many are boarding you know
without transference what is the first
boarding okay
nobody okay the question when they ask
this question uncle me would answer the
question reservist system but I was
wondering what is the question for which
this is the answer whatever planning
problem are they trying to solve with
this one okay it's very interesting very
Singapore if you've been there it's like
the rain pours there's no umbrellas that
can help you
okay just not you just wait out okay
they have waiting time at the bus
stations in the train station you have
tappings you know when they went into
this station in the pasta station they
tap at the bus thank you so the problem
was this because it's rain the awnings
weren't long enough a car in some
commuters are complaining the awnings
that were sheltering people from the
rain wasn't long enough at the bus stop
okay so could you please increase this
and now the question is you know what
size and so this is just a you know two
or three commuters and complain and then
never look at it seriously okay quantify
it and then send somebody to fix it okay
so it's sort of things like this that
happen all the time every time like
every day there's not ten of these
complaints that come okay very
interesting okay many smething the city
dependent like some Paulo's its own its
own sort of set of questions it was run
differently and you know so I hope you
sort of see this there's interesting
things with the big data system the one
can do algorithmically as well as it's
very interesting to answer questions
okay
and I do think that this particular
brand of work is very suited for
academics because you can work with the
government and they'll be you know
reaching an agreement to give you the
data and then the way we worked was
pretty much how you could one could do
it and there's enough government grants
to support this sort of thing and I
think this certainly wasn't the case
around 2008 2010 because we even know
this problem but now I think look one
can make a case okay so some other fun
stuff this is from chen-wong juice
thesis New York City Taxi released New
York taxi nosing Commission released
this data and many people have seen it
similar to this thing we you know you
get the start and end points or trips
plus dollars earned in that trip plus
tips plus how many passengers there's a
bunch of things you get okay was it paid
by cash or credit card those sort of
things okay
in the case of cash for example you
can't separate trip tips from there okay
cuz you don't know how much tips were
sent home is trips are given an X you
know what the fare was very
the person got dipped how much that was
okay so with that I'm going to show you
something but these are ubiquitous we've
seen this also in trains data so one
thing is when I said you take the
neighborhoods of Manhattan and
superimpose it on the map
so these are some neighbors like midtown
Manhattan pickups from these places are
the thing I'm trying to show you here is
a highly periodic okay so in the morning
I think or as you can it so it's true
whether you're looking at the whole day
or the morning so this is 24 hours okay
24 hours is how many people what time
zero hours to 24 hours and the number of
people being picked up in midtown
Manhattan so if you look at Sunday
Monday Tuesday like that okay sorry this
is Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday
so Monday's are highly similar Tuesday's
this is true not just in New York for
taxis it's true anyway this is just a
urban commuting is super periodic okay
the exceptions are round here that's the
May the Memorial Day weekend in that
year okay but it's super periodic this
you can use this to like flat plan your
fleets okay
this was true for Train happens in fact
this is so periodic for amusement
we took the fullier transform of this
senator music just you can hear the
sound of pickups in Manhattan oh it's
not right today okay can like hear it
okay this is a distinct sound so this is
financial district again you know the
periodicity amongst the dates themselves
okay
Brooklyn etc so the implication is that
human movement in most urban systems of
the movement type especially people move
by mass movement is highly periodic and
it strongly geography geography depend
this is not just for pickups but also
where distance travel things like this
so you're a fairly
we'll load and it changes gradually or
time but you know in a short period he
can learn it Sheng Wang species has some
analysis of this and I'm not going to
show that you can you can ask the
question now that I've seen the taxi
data could have done the scheduling of
this fleet in some way with some
assumptions and what the scheduler is
allowed to know could that have been
more efficient okay
I'm not answering that question here but
that's an interesting scheduling problem
detecting anomalies due to weather and
special events understanding demand
latent demand so sometimes if there's
like lots of rain and people haven't
come on a particular day then you know
because they're a usually come but they
will come ok this is true at bus stops
just because you've seen them doesn't
mean they're there they're gonna come
please waiting the rain they're waiting
out the rain ponchos is say assumptions
the observation that people people live
in the same place and return to it daily
that's why it is happening there's a
well I see what you mean no you're right
so they're not exactly all going to work
so this is the morning peak hour this
evening peak hour okay maybe slightly
different that's right but that includes
things like you know school pickups
whereas other things right so but the
point I'm making is you know of itself
every days we're similar okay
okay so this is one there's several
things like you can analyze the US Open
you can analyze cultural things like
that or what happens in the UN Security
Council meets in September they shot off
the roads
we saw the bike data that's available
that went up okay so these are all class
projects without kind of the fun type
difference here the data and there's a
system as well one can use ok so here's
one that is just for amusement I think
it's fun
the fans tip more when the team wins
versus when they lose okay so here's a
New York Knicks played the Spurs
Celtics Bulls and magic and they won to
the last two okay and then if you look
at so what you would do is you go to
Madison Square Garden select a region
around it were 50 meter fence around
geofence or Madison Square Garden or 100
meter and then you say look at pickups
from here at the time that the game
finished because that's known that time
is precisely known and then see what the
tips were okay and you did it for these
two types of days but also did for other
days where there's no game just to you
know normalize and there's a small
increase this one you know what Aiden
18.1 went to 19 but as a percentage is
5% roughly or like if I wouldn't change
ok it's it's statistically significant
because the p-value is small okay so
this isn't necessarily very persuasive
for us perhaps ok are you persuaded or a
convincing or you want to see yeah okay
luckily for us New York City taxis the
tipping is a particular this is a
certain method if you've taken this you
sort of as soon as you swipe your card
or you know the right finishes they say
especially the card 20% is the norm you
know using normalize your English at the
20 percent if you don't choose to do
something different and then by hand you
have to say 25 or 30 or 15 or 10 or
enter a different number altogether this
is a you have to act additionally I'll
give this okay so let's look at the PDF
of tipping okay so this is what I'm
showing you here is the PDF where Knicks
lost
so when Knicks won the green the small
bump down from the default 20% okay and
it bumps up here a 25 a small bump or 30
but mostly here or in Knicks lose
there's a small reverse bump okay but
this is somebody else it's somebody's
tipping when the Knicks lost its tipping
you know so New Yorkers tip some
somebody sleeping less but somebody's
tipping more and normal okay and that
was on the one hand we can look at where
the people who are taking these rides so
this is the Knicks fans themselves one
presumes but the people are tipping more
when the Knicks lose one expects is the
opposite team that lost that they're not
happy but you don't have to just rest
can't you know content yourself with
that hypothetical explanation you can
see where those rides ending because
available are they going to the hotel or
you know poured bars or you know some of
these transit stops okay so that was
also done earning an extra information
which suggested those guys are from the
visiting team right so like this you can
do a whole bunch of analyses with the
data okay this is sort of scratching the
surface but and it's a lot of very
information I think my feeling is you
know as going to cities as a tourist you
only learn some things about the city is
almost learning you know straightforward
you know superficial things that would
be very touristy knowledge once you
start looking at this stuff it's really
are essentially okay so I encourage you
to cut you know find a way to get this
first thing going in your research so
that's it for the big data system for
inaudible to demo it it's not with us
anymore so but but I hope I've given you
the idea but I can show you a demo of
this is on YouTube of what this tap in
tap or basting after you reconstruct the
whole train movement and everything what
it looks like there's a youtube promo
video subscribe to the preamble to the
point where you can see this so this is
actually what the reconstruction will
look like okay namely
so what disease is this is some city
anonymized to be not representing any
particular city okay so once you've
reconstructed locations or trains and
assigned passengers to these trains you
can see that some are filled in and some
are less filled in is how many people
are in each train you can see this for
the whole 24-hour period and then there
is gross numbers on how many total
passengers unique riders how many trips
how many missed at least two trains and
how many had to wait for ten minutes or
more okay so this is sort of metrics
that people care about I'm just going to
let this play out this is San Paulo
[Music]
using your already available data like
fair card data or to the yes traces
urban engines reconstructs the movement
of your commuters and vehicles for any
given dangerous at any time for any rock
rendering a digital replica of your
transportation system in the seconds
alerts are raised automatically with
hits
add comments to stay coordinated with
columns and operations and planning or
visit the alert summary page to see
recurring patterns at a particular
location or tongue export or share any
of the beautifully use and presentations
or to conduct further analysis you can
also use urban tensions flexible query
and relay engine
[Music]
troubleshoot incidents and repair system
performance over different time areas
the spot tracks get answers to your
questions
so this was the system for public
transit but because the buses and
everything I think as an academic
project this is this III think this
would be something out two or three
universities could get together and do
this I will be very useful for the
systems in question but also as a thing
to do increase the demand bill there old
what's gonna help but somewhere just
unhide couple slides and skit
optimization engine was the idea of like
I already I'm not gonna increase my
capacity I want to flip my trains around
and keep the demand closer to supply or
also have some plate holding areas for
buses so I could deploy them faster in
the peak hour there's something many
systems do this one is the emulation
engine I was saying we built this this
had more the predictive thing is the
two-pointer making think or is a
data-driven thing right what if I are an
extra train in the peak hour that would
that how much you know will not help
things like that okay
anyway that was the and this is for San
Francisco for the Muni system okay so so
you can't do that and I think there's a
lot of value to doing that and it's also
true for just even you know places like
India where the National Railways is
moving a lot of people and that's all
available the the tracks GPS you know
pads are available it's a file you just
get it okay and the schedule of trains
is published all that's missing is who
garden and where they get off that's
ticketing information that your the work
with the railways as an example okay but
the moment you build it and Switzerland
they're all available online Germany
there's one of us
hoping to do but I'm back in the world
of cloud computing so that's why I'm
doing it but I think it's very easy and
I believe it's easy you can set up a
system for trains and then the data
might come okay so that's really the
other questions on the data system
son conclude with some work from chin my
man James thesis where he analyzed
incentive programs in the road traffic
highway model context okay
the such a thing there's a famous
highway model you liked real LWR okay
I feel something with them and Robins
purchase but it's a famous model
light-filled I believe that's right he
was the location professor at Cambridge
Newton at Cambridge University so a
differential equations type person
developed this model and even it now is
very popularly used and you know you can
start with darling then that gives you a
map and I'll walk us through that okay
okay so
so modeling congestion costs under
adduction through incentive is worth
paying people to travel off-peak is the
resulting amount of gain in dollar terms
to the you know as I reduce congestion
so this is what some amount of time and
fuel is are worth it
relative to the money I'm paying out if
so what's the optimal type it's just one
can get okay so the answer these
questions I'm gonna introduce this
highway model and it's a roll of length
X miles
let's model the morning peak hour so it
starts low this is like one of those
things you've already seen starts logos
iron comes down this is the morning peak
hour assuming that nothing else is taken
so this is the mass of way cuz we were
to look at that I'm gonna enter this
highway and come out so the area under
this curve represents the number of
vehicles in the morning peak hour the
ascent aeneas rate is lambda of T is the
number of vehicles running at time T and
the cumulative traffic is the integral
and the things that matter are the
density at location X at time T and the
velocity as well and the product of the
density and velocity is called the flux
the number of vehicles crossing segment
at a time for a good time for any time
coming for the velocity okay no vehicles
per second crossing a location on a
given time and it's possible the
vehicles were arrived in the peak time
was you know the traffic was exceeding
capacity so it got flattened out so the
area and the egress you know thing is
equal to the area under this one but
it's just instantaneous rates are
different okay being respectively lambda
sub D lowercase and uppercase
okay let me give this alright this is
the LWR model I apologize I just I'm
blanking on the name
I only reminded myself where it was this
morning so light Hills thank you
Windham son Richard Richards okay thank
you like hell okay so you can there's
two considerations here one is its
conservation of mass so what went in has
to come out when you write that down you
get this so-called advection equation
it's the discrete version is pretty easy
to derive it would be literally at a
given cross-section look at the rate at
which thinks the the the flux of what
came in does that rivals per unit time
and what's leaving so the difference has
to be in the Q in a segment that's what
this is okay yeah roughly okay it's not
come this one is it's not compressible
it the first term is change in a city oh
I see okay yeah you're right in that but
yeah it's compressible what was I
thinking
yeah it's compressible for that reason
yes
we use the lower bound on it this is the
distance between two cars so I'll tell
you what our model is and that has a
lower bound
you can't compress it to less than
something and the velocity the densities
depends on the velocity in other words
measured as vehicles per mile per lane
how many vehicles per mile per Lane as
it grows the speed drops so the Norway
cuz there are the slower things will
tend to go okay and then that's the
speed versus density diagram but there's
the one that you know flow versus
density is typically what matters
because it captures the the processing
capability of the highway so the optimal
speed is somewhere here that's the point
okay
the corresponding to the density so it's
somewhere there okay that's the most you
can do and so velocity some function of
density we've taken a very simple one
you can plug in whatever the equation is
but we've taken one way it was less than
the free flow there is there is free
flow if you're less than some critical
density theta then the velocity is the
velocity of this of the highway speed
limit so this could be 55 miles an hour
or 60 miles an hour whatever the speed
limit is that's the free flow velocity
it is more than this critical value then
it comes this velocity drops to some
critical value we see which is less than
we have so it looks like this
okay as the solving this PDE it's an
equation of the hyperbolic type meaning
the x and y variables there's a DX DX by
DT term partial and it's equal to some
negative of x times y term so that's
that give us a map
okay so I'll show you how so you can
solve this PDE but it's discontinuity in
this velocity and the velar diagram
gives you non uniqueness you end up
basically having these shock waves which
is typical the paper by light field and
Williams like Hill and Williams is
actually very nice to read it's written
in super plain English I think Leiter
was keen to have this model being like
clearly understood by the users and is
really very clearly done okay it's
available online you can just search for
it I think it richards joined later and
it reaches us from America and the
lights and Williams were from there two
papers got released and they got merged
into this single model there's no paper
with LW & R together is LW no okay so
the person who studied this sort of
thing quite heavily is Peter lacks has
one of the science limb volumes to get
rid of this non uniqueness he has an
entropy condition which most models have
done since what we did was surround 2003
newell introduced the so-called
look-ahead condition the look-ahead
condition says that from a local cars
perspective there's no global for
density and velocity diagrams were just
look at it from a cars perspective its
goal is to maintain a certain distance
to the car in front of it which distance
you know increases the faster the cars
are going so the cops are going slow I
don't mind being close to the guy in
front of me if I we're going fast I want
to give more distance okay that's his
model from that everything else emerges
okay
and as a stochastic version of this one
can analyze two
okay that's what he did so we used this
condition and you end up getting the
same result as this unique solution as
what you would have got if your news
entropy condition and that gives us a
method of solving this PDE for every X
and T to be saying something about the
whole peak hour and to get you know
something that's not dependent on a
location in time we took the so called
long highway limit which means for X
large enough highways long enough then
you know the the thing that was squeezed
through our a cheers equilibrium rate
the the the density of vehicles arriving
lambda of T well of squeezed thrown
become lambda of D and there's there's a
distance there's a value of x at which
this can be shown to happen okay and so
then this system ends up being a coolant
or single silver cube where the amount
of time spent from ingress to egress
equals the time delay the time taken to
traverse this highway at that speed so
you just add that and then you get the
delay okay so what went in less what
came out has to be in the cute that's me
right okay now this has some interesting
consequences and you can fix the T and
an X and do everything I'm saying it's
really up to you okay but in order for
the conservation to work here to let the
entire peak hour go through that's T so
accumulator dials less cumulative
departures equals what's in the queue so
now I'm going to introduce this variable
so we have an optimization problem this
is just a map this is it relates input
to output
now I want to analyze this map right the
cost of congestion cost of congestion
let's remind ourselves is not the time
taken to travel but the extra time due
to being stuck in traffic
the user eye enters the highway at some
time a sub I and Exeter sometime D sub I
so if we subtract from this difference
they're trying to traverse the highway
in free flow conditions the extra time
is the so called waiting time okay we're
trying to minimize that we're trying to
minimize that by shifting the peak if
possible so if you look at and that's
clearly a function of the arrival rate
profile so you know so the more peak it
is the more even to have waiting more
waiting is incurred okay
I'm assuming that we're not losing
people all I'm doing is just sort of
arranging you know rearranging what time
they come to the highway by
incentivizing them to come at off-peak
times so in all of this the total mass
is held a constant okay of the of the
peak hour traffic so for every one of
those profiles the cost of congestion
equals some of the waiting times this is
simply a well known thing in killing and
so it is one of those things you
integrate either horizontally or
vertically there is the same area so the
integral of the Q equals some of the
waiting times and this is linear cost of
congestion I could stick up to the power
alpha here I'll be not linear okay and
we could have different classes of
traffic where people are some people
don't care as much about waiting and
some people do you know further
refinements now to measure this cost of
congestion and express it in some way
that depends on lambda and lambda D is
an exercise to go through right so
there's a so called
D bar distance it's also known as the
earthmovers distance and what it does is
I can I will define it you look at all
joint distributions
with marginals given by lambda and
lambda D so these are just functions
that look like probabilities they may
not integrate to one but other than that
their probabilities are equal in mass
and you look at that okay take that
joint distribution which minimizes this
expected difference so let's pick random
variables x and y from this Joint
Distribution one particular distribution
is specified by this gamma and gamma is
the Joint Distribution one of them that
specifies I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
show you what this means with an X with
the examples okay this is turns out that
this is exactly relating the cost of
congestion okay and this is something in
evaluate explicitly
so here's how you think of it so lambda
a time one one or one car arrived at
time two two cars arrived this is an
example of in discrete setting of an
arrival profile and the corresponding
departure profile let's say looks like
this okay so six plus three nine cars
arrives and 8 + 1 9 cars left and every
car got held for at least one unit of
time so but T sub X and the highways on
capacity and no more than two cars can
go at a time
so the third guy is pushed over and
pushed over okay look you this that's it
so here's a couple of marginal
distributions what are some joint
distributions that go with this these
marginals here's one okay
okay and this is the diagonal what's the
cost of this if I pick up a random
variables an accident of Y X comma Y is
this and I'm looking at the absolute
different through an x and y so if I
have one guy here
then the difference is whatever is off
the diagonals are 1 2 3 4 as this 4 off
of this diagonal is up 1 plus a 2 that's
this 3 and this 6 is 1 plus 2 plus 3 and
then this is a down such absolute value
so 1 plus 2 that's 3 6 3 1 that's this
one every okay this this is an example
of a Joint Distribution with those
marginals but at the cost of 17 so it's
not an optimal coupling or it's not an
optimal Joint Distribution here's
another one you do the same calculation
it will cost you 13 here's an optimal
one ok so you get the point that it put
as much mass and dactyl as possible or
as close to diagonalize is allowed
because you have a delay okay every okay
this this is an example you've just told
us Buster's time distance is equivalent
to first eat first day out yeah what
kind of underwear conservation
okay usually any work conserving
discipline as a community I found this
interesting it's not obvious okay
and it is interesting okay so like wait
let's see he's thinking to see baby is
like so it's interesting
oh you're looking over there okay it's a
simple thing which is interesting just
because you don't think of comparing
input and output in this math sense but
in a busy cycle the number of went in
number came out our optimally coupled
it's kind of interesting under no
further constrains excel or conservation
okay so for the optimal Joint
Distribution it's not difficult rly not
difficult well sir requires a proof it's
not obvious there's actually a whole
paper that we found subsequently proving
this fact okay in generality okay
there's no mass below the diagonal okay
and so this is it and the reason I was
introducing this in some at some length
is that this is after this quantity
which were interested in optimizing is
equal to this which you can calculate
plus everything else is known but this
is just account you can forget there's a
constant it's not it there's an optimize
this is a highway length is this there's
the speed limit this is the number of
vehicles coming in the pickup and
nothing to optimize okay so you can
reduce this by reducing that okay so I
have to find an optimal so I can't
change lambda what I want to find is so
I have to change how to find the right
lambda that is some lambda tilde the has
some constraints for example its overall
mass equals the same as lambda and I
don't want to move people to 5:00 a.m.
it's like there's some constraints let's
go through that now first of all and
this is the problem so I want to move
this is what's happening today I sent
people through highway they come out
much later that's gotta cost and I want
to work out this community of diagram
like things I want to shift my original
input to sound friendlier thing
I will do this with paying some money
but then I send that through the highway
map and this comes out I want that this
Plus this is smaller than that okay then
it's worth spending the money that's it
okay now this problem in order solve it
you would like that this function has
some useful properties and this is
another calculation chinmaya actually I
thought it this is a nice way of doing
it he just showed that this function is
convex in lambda so there's a water sign
distance is Congress in lambda okay
which is not something it's not
surprised when you hear it but it's not
obvious either and and the cost function
is based as a linear thing but it
doesn't have to be just linear you could
have a to the Alpha is very true and so
you can do this it's convex therefore
you can consider the cost of shifting
and user arrival time from AI to AI
prime so if you're coming at 8:05 I want
you to come at 7:55 there's certain cost
and that's the cost is taken to be just
like the you know waiting time is linear
okay if I have to move you by 10 minutes
I pay you some constant times 10 minutes
what are dollars so by 20 minutes the
same constant times 20 minutes how do I
shift there's this sort of you know
variable which has placed the following
row I get a shifted input from the
original by looking at how much got
shifted into time T from s how much got
shifted out of time T into a see that's
basically one of the shift math works
and total cost is this integral
okay and it's linear because that's what
I started that's what I assumed I'm
gonna pay you
let me locate this all right so it's all
set up now and I have to show that you
know this is true and that's the main
theorem is basically long okay so the
main theorem is that this is true but
that's you know if you pick under
constraints of the type that are
implementable you can pick it and you'll
save some money
so let's go quantified here's an
unrealistic example the under listing
example is where I'm taking everybody
who came between 8:00 and 8:30 all of
these people in excess of Laura arrived
brunette an attorney I'm going to move
them to the previous half hour okay it's
unrealistic because you're not going to
get this kind of oh you know commuter
response this is asking for too much if
you do it then you have a before and
after lambda and you can work out the
cost is 37% are you here 37% reduction
in total cost so the money is well worth
your spending it
I just won't get people taking it up so
gently shift is you move only 10% the so
that the cost of the change plus they
say the increase is smaller than one so
that the personal cost like the cost of
cooks do you have some assumption on us
how much is the cost of shifting it is
linear so I pay if I'm 15 by 10 minutes
I pay some constant times 10 minutes
I've just taken everyone for the
calculations okay but before not
changing but you can put in a different
value in general is related to the cost
you assess for delay as well so how much
nuisance is being cost to you for the 10
minutes extra time you hope held in
traffic because I can
okay and that should norm how much I'm
willing to pay you exactly but this is
the reason I've left them even if some
constants the same is that the
presumption we've made here is for this
particular example but in pay from the
papers like in there it's a variable one
unit of expense stuck in traffic minute
equals 1 unit of is how much you are
willing to accept as payment to shift
okay so if you have everybody so what is
this line this is where the congestion
kicks in so all these this is under this
limit the freeway is not going to get
congested beyond this is the freeway
gets congestion this is the this is the
traffic that you want to shift okay
that's what this lines I didn't say it
before so it's the moving everybody I
just take ten percent of the people will
donate an 8:30 no I'm not hope you know
there's an example is a representation
10% and then I move them by some amount
and so you get 16 points on your side
there's an example how you can calculate
I can calculate these things okay so
that's basically you know concludes this
there are some generalizations but but
you know the point is that this is also
something you could generalize on apply
to trains because it still this there's
no doll arrival rate no roll departure
rate of people waited for some amount of
time but there you may want to assess a
cost for crowdedness in the train which
we didn't have people don't like not to
be sitting at there's other things okay
but but it is pleasing that that cost is
you know a function of just the arrival
and departure rates you know when you
take is just the waiting time etc there
is talk
take a couple of questions and think
that this would work in urban because
you've used highway model and urban the
dynamics of urban congestion rather
really different from those of highway
congestion know most of the congestion
tolling is only for highways that's why
we restricted our highways once people
are on streets there's nothing there's
nothing to do you can only incentivize
and not to get there that's the trains
problem more than the roads problem but
congestion tolling is on highways and
also you have ramp meters that's that's
really the advantage of highway systems
worldwide because they're in a closed
ecosystem you can only enter and exit
through specific Rams and they're
metered them and then the equations of
line that's the difference but you'll
have to solve this PDE not the the long
highway model goes out you know because
you need to solve
yeah for a xnt do you see evidence of
Jevons paradox in this kind of system so
you kind of move the traffic around so
the traffic is ease so everyone who
would otherwise leave at a later time or
an earlier time would start going giving
the field traffic light because you know
that the condition has been aged because
10% of the people have moved in before
so this was where this is a good
question and it comes up all the time in
public policy in this kind this is like
this is like the go-to argument okay for
why you should do congestion charging
anyway meaning there's a deterrent which
is not the absence of congestion but
there's a condition charge and then the
incentives are there too as an extra
thing to ameliorate exactly but I think
in general you know people who come
it's a there's an equilibrium with reach
I don't think it's required that you
have to have a pricing type argument I
think the incentives will hold people
that's the point of incentives that's
why because there's also an argument
about incentives of behavior shifting so
how long do I need to keep pain he's new
even already shifted well usually my
argument is why need remove congestion
charging you've been charging people now
for 25 years or 30 years or whatever
isn't the behavior shifted I'm the
learnt it what are the non guruship
okay so it can't be you know hard
arguments on one side and soft arguments
on the other side
take that I have an announcement please
unfortunately